women women make less money but spent
own two-thirds of the world's debt even
though we make ten to fifteen thousand
dollars pounds less than men per year
and so we have less money and we spend
more
hundred percent i never thought about it
yeah we're impulsive yeah yeah but it's
really important we're chemically
different we can't
we can't help it we have salt we're
adults but like like on some primal
level we're chemically different every
day
so
like we're we're more like emotional
beings yeah yeah we're more likely to
respond to to make impulsive decisions
that's what it is
and your friends are not going to help
you because she wants to make those
decisions as well so it's like the only
person that's really there is the guy
that's just like the cheap guy that we
called it you know what i'm saying he's
controlling the final like no you can't
keep doing this babes like you know i
mean like we can't afford it we need
distant distant distances that came
through the left no that's the letter
that's why we date higher
so